and he was like talking to me like he
was a fan and then he's like yeah um I
see you your b-boy and and you know this
guy from this city and you know this B
boy from that state and I was like yeah
like I used to train with that guy
and then he he like gets really close to
my face and he literally says
hey I didn't know facts could break too
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys today we have Bart Nick
Anthony Joe myself and Steve
boys are back don't even can somewhere
he lives here yeah and candy now that
we're all together let's do an OTR from
the fans this one is from Kaizen he
wanted to know what is the weirdest fan
interaction you've ever had oh where do
I even start dude start you have a bunch
of them all of mine we kind of forget
but we have so many throughout the years
dude
recent ones maybe we could think of
those one of the more recent ones that
comes to mind
um
so I think a lot of fans bless their
hearts some they want to like support
the stuff that we do like our businesses
and stuff
one of them he became a member at the at
the gym borrower game
and then there's just a lot of like
weird signs the first one was he uh
bought a Year's worth of membership at
once is that bad yeah people don't do
that they just you just have to use pay
monthly and they paid it all in ones and
a duffel bag so that was weird
and then there it's really weird did he
also let you keep the duffel bag because
that's weirder I don't know I wasn't did
I just I just hear the stories and then
there's uh one time he brought in a
chick to train like kickboxing this guy
does not know anything about kickboxing
and he just beat the [__] out of her
come on she's the one holding pad oh
[__] I don't know why yeah she was
holding pads for him but he's training
her and then okay so the first thing you
said huh that's the point against him
this is a point for him
he's like you gotta show dominance I
showed her wait did I say coolest or
weird
[Laughter]
and then uh there's this and then he
started to like you know
and he's training her and they started
to come around uh pretty regularly so
like you know like we're a culture-based
gym so everyone kind of knows each other
yeah just sort of make friends and then
he brought in this gun you know
you bring a gun into the show people and
then people what the [__] whatever got
here he'd pull the trigger and it was
just like a flame ah he thought it was a
[__] oh my God he's the Joker yeah so we
ended up having to uh revoke his
membership yeah but that was pretty
smart that was because you giving back
the duffel bag and that's the last you
saw of him he didn't come back or
anything
nah
oh and then he would uh his mom would
drop him off and then he would train for
like four hours and his mom's just in
the car in the front just the car's
running the whole time just waiting with
the AC on yeah well there you have it
that's the reason why so how did you
that's the end of the video thanks I've
ever heard about did you know he was a
fan did he like say anything yeah he was
a big fan I've always wanted to come
here and enjoy them that's the sign
right there no oh geez oh geez dude I
was at a uh uh theme park and just enjoy
my time
and this this fan comes up he goes John
what are you doing here and I'm like
same thing what everyone else is doing
you know like enjoying I thought he
wanted a picture no way there's no way
that's why you're here a guy like you
probably here to film something yeah he
was like can I ask you something and I
was like thinking oh you probably want a
picture right
and then we're like in the middle of
like a ride like just going back and
forth right and then like in the middle
of it we're I'm just about to go and he
goes can I ask you something I was like
oh yeah you probably like quick picture
like same routine and I was like sure
and he goes yeah so when I first um saw
your videos you know it really inspired
me and all that and then like he just
goes on this [__] novel and then
we're almost next in line right and then
I'm like yo we're about to like no
social contacts and in the middle of it
he's trying to talk about Jesus to me
and then I'm he goes uh and I'm like
yeah yeah like I yeah I believe in you
know all this stuff whatever whatever
you think
[Music]
that's great I was like that's great you
love God like cool I love God we're on
the same team okay I love this rock I
was like hey good to meet you whatever
right yeah finish the ride this guy's
still waiting for me at the stairs so we
could continue talking about Jesus and
he's like can we pray he's witnessing
and I'm like hey dude not to be
offensive but like we're in like we're
in the middle of enjoying this thing and
I ain't gonna stand here and talk to you
all this time and just [__] have a 30
minute prayer like what are you doing
like I just got off the Riddler bro and
his eyes his eyes was like dead [__]
serious like this nothing behind the
eyes and I was just trying to tell him
like this is the wrong time and place to
be [__] evangelizing to me
and it's like what are you doing
but I was just like at that point I was
pissed because I was like what the [__]
is wrong with you like you have no
social context like what are you [__]
[__] did you ask him that
I don't know I I always like to believe
people mean well and they don't
understand
how social cues they're not being
socially correct yes right yes it's like
the the normal transaction with a
stranger or someone that you admire or
whatever is hey quick words thank you
very much all right we're go we got we
both got things to do we're in a [__]
theme park dude what are you doing
trying to
tell me like you're the first person
that ever talked to me about God like
the [__] you know like I don't know dude
yeah you're right though I would talk
about God before maybe going on Tatsu
but not after yeah because after top
scary you're just we're leaving the
house I made it in the tattoo photo that
would have been the perfect time bless
up yeah because that's scary dude times
are scary your feet are dangling dude we
should all go to Six Flags people lose
their shoes
on the ref right baptized by the raft
water dude I wouldn't even mind he's
done your head real quick hey real quick
I'm gonna do a quick little 30 second
prayer with you real quick like he if he
told me no in the time duration I would
have been like I'm out but that's that's
how far I'm down to go I was like yo
you're a writer yeah his he
AP his welcome is what I felt like it's
like dude this is this is too long I got
Life to Live and you're out here like
having a deep trying to have a deep ass
conversation trying to get to X2 right
now really that's the problem with
evangelism is that like witnessing for
the Lord's probably one of the toughest
[__] sales jobs you could possibly
take yeah and they're throwing amateurs
the [__] uh Reigns yeah and they're
just like go for it yeah
we should go do it at Six Flags too dude
that's honestly that's the highest
difficulty he's trying to get he's
trying to make head faster dude he's at
the water park he's [__] in the wave
pool and he's [__] excuse me about
Jesus not easy we could turn this into
wine
and then and then and you know all these
stories right where like people turn
around and then they go man he was such
a dick yeah and I'm like I'm trying to
that's true yeah but there's a point
where you gotta go happen hey you're
being rude like what are you doing I
remember there was this one time we were
all we were we we were waiting forever
to [__] eat at this restaurant we
finally got sat down the food comes
we're just [__] chowing right
and this [__] mom comes up and then
she goes can my can my kids take
pictures with you guys they're big fans
and then we're like lady like we're
eating you should be the person that
[__] sets a good example for your
kids
like and the way she came up was like
my kids are big fans you guys take a
picture right now call them yeah and I
was like yo we're thankful but we need
um but but can you let us finish it's
just normal even interaction yeah I was
like it worked she had that like
authoritative mom Vibe so she was kind
of mad coming in like she's like I don't
know who you guys are but my kids love
you guys you need to take pictures with
them that's like demeaning at the same
time so I felt like oh I gotta teach
teach her a lesson and I'd be like we'll
do it after this meal and she goes real
quick and I'm like nah we'll do it after
this meal and then she looked at me with
with like like that and walked away oh
yeah I know man and then they weren't
around they didn't wait around but
that's four subscribers dude and that's
how it started it down
I could see it in the chart couldn't
even hit two
actually would have done it like we do
it all the time we stop in the middle of
the meal to [__] take pictures all
the fun all the time all the time just
how she asked yeah this is to me yeah
dude it was like Brazil because we were
what in our 20s at the time too so I
think she felt like yes your kids need
to [__] do what I say and I was just
like which is a weird way to enter
anything yeah so much about it it's the
foreplay you know what I mean how you
butter somebody up and make them feel
good about the fans if they were nice
and they were just open like hey big
fans and they this is the tone change
I'm sure it wouldn't have been a problem
yeah and the follow-up was like yeah
we'll do it like you know just let us
finish our meal real quick yeah it's
nice still polite but the after response
of like oh yeah like you guys think
you're so [__] dude yeah and I was
like you know what
the weird fan interactions I feel like
it's the it's the it's their approach
and how they talk to you yeah it's never
like gonna be talking like that from
anybody I've been interrupted in my meal
multiple times and I [__] love it
sometimes because they're cool because
they walk up and you're just like oh
this guy's [__] cool and then they
might even sit down while I'm just like
eating my meal and I'm finishing it
while I'm having a full-on conversation
with them because I enjoy their company
because they're nice yeah yeah it's cool
or they're hot and you [__] yes guys and
girls
let's go there was um two hands during
the time this is 2005 and um I was on
sale you think you could dance and then
this was like mid as the show was like
broadcasting so we were still on like
the I think the top 32 and that night we
were staying at the Universal Hilton or
whatever right by the Universal Studios
so we decided to go to Saddle Ranch at
CityWalk where it used to be
um we all went out there and tons of
people recognizing us because because it
was like the whole cast is out so if you
knew one person you knew it was the
whole show all these people were talking
to us this dude comes up to me and I I
think he's a fan because he's like yo
what's up you're Ryan what's up man and
he was like talking to me like he was a
fan and then he's like yeah um I see you
your B boy and and you know this guy
from this city and you know this b-boy
from that state I was like yeah like I
used to train with that guy
and then he [__] he like gets really
close to my face and he literally says
hey I didn't know facts could break too
oh that's and then at that point Steve
Green Line he was about to Sock me right
there but the guard saw the way he was
talking to me the whole time and he was
coming up and he grabbed the guy right
before I got sucked wow and they kicked
him out and then everybody was like what
was that and I was just like shook so he
was a hater that just came and he wanted
to [__] you up he thought it was great
he thought it was and then you looked at
him he's like weak
so he was a gay hater but he was I guess
he was also a b-boy back in the days
but he thought I was he actually he was
in love with you and he's like if I
can't have him nobody can he's like the
dad from American Beauty yeah he thought
it was actually gay and was like pissed
that I was a b-boy on the show because I
was gay and he turned out to be so as a
straight man you got gay bash I honestly
was shook because I felt what that might
be like and I was like holy [__] I was
nice to this guy everything was cool he
was about to get back and then he like
it was so creepy because in this crowded
ass it's all loud everyone's talking and
he [__] I thought it changed like
that a Cool Secret and he's just like
gives it so he was being aggressive but
you're so positive yeah that you're just
not even taking it that way because I
was so used because he was aggressive
enough to where the security guard was
like oh [__] you know how good security
knows when that's about to happen yeah
and then he was like he just got real
close and then as soon as that [__]
happened I just saw arms come around him
and they just tossed him out watching
videos of you though I will say that I'm
like oh Ryan was gay he's straight now
no he's not yeah yeah I mean his hair
was he converted
it works yeah it's successful yeah it
was successful at him he's a little
catatonic but it's okay
because when when Ryan had
um a Karen haircut
my gayness
you did oh yeah well I did yeah I did
but yeah that was you're not like
grinding I think I still look at that as
the weirdest interaction because it was
like you think it's a fan that's weird
and then he wants to kick your ass
that's wild dude he's like but the fact
that he like did his research is crazy
that's why I think he was gay and like
repressed oh yeah cause that's a lot of
reasons because he was obsessing he
knows your name and all this stuff yeah
because I think he had like hated me
throughout the whole like watching it
and go oh this [__] gay guy better
not make it he's like I'm gonna get this
gay guy at Saddle Ranch I'm gonna show
him what's really good right when he's
on the bull ride most most haters are
dedicated fans they're obsessed yeah
it's true yeah they care and they follow
you for years and if if they really
didn't
give a [__] about you
pay so much attention yeah they take a
hell of real estate yeah yeah yeah hi JK
Reddit
[Laughter]
I mean
because well they were they used to be
hilarious I will yeah but they're big
fans that's why they stay around so long
they love us and they know details that
everything yeah everything I'm like
because like no one follows every single
one of our stuff like even our Die Hard
fans don't even watch every single thing
that we do you guys don't miss a beat
and I do like that they stick up for
Anthony a lot
okay [__]
do they yeah they do what do they say no
they they really believe that because
they believe he's really being bullied
I'm just glad that you converted yeah
yeah well it's probably because I wish
you convert back we do get bullied so
they so they feel that obviously yeah
well look obviously a lot of them I
don't think have friends and that's and
that's okay I'm not even
make know how friendship Works to
interact with each other yeah and yeah
dunking on Anthony does not mean that we
don't like the guy like we come here we
put on our basketball shoes and we
[__] dumb and we don't we're doing
layup lines dude but with dunks they
for us it's exhausting to dunk for 12
hours a [__] day yeah for a three day
because it's so successful though that's
what I'm saying but we alley-oop each
other a lot what's your weirdest thing
I'm not contributing to this
conversation because this is the exact
topic where Bart dunked on me the first
time oh really
nah you have to dude hold on years ago I
think that's been when the numbers do
number two started starting really I
mean if you guys didn't even win those
because we were talking about weird fan
interactions I don't even remember yeah
it's because you know I'm obsessed about
it and I remember it's crazy you still
remember
so this being like noticed is new for
you right so like you're kind of
experiencing fans for the first time and
people recognizing you how does that
yeah how does that feel like
um I'll say this everyone that's around
me when someone comes up to me they
always go why are you so weird they say
that to me yeah yeah what because I
started like I don't like dude it's like
we don't know how to interact it's weird
I don't want to make too much eye
contact I try to be as friendly as I can
but then sometimes like the first couple
times some people came up to me it just
caught me off guard so hard like I just
didn't know what to say maybe one of
these like
I was like okay
okay I do that
no I don't know it's it's everyone's
been really nice there hasn't been
anyone that's weird there's calling to
me and was like a little weird hey this
Arrow JK pens is sick though legit yeah
it's the best it's the weirdest one when
I came up to it
that was that was one of the funniest
[__] things I've ever seen in my life
like I I couldn't believe and then the
whole backstory was insane uh but most
people have been really nice I remember
there was one girl I forgot I forgot her
name but we were in a big island she
came up to us me and Tiff were just
shopping at a [__] gift shop Hawaiian
fans are the best too yeah hey Hawaiian
fans are the [__] bro and this this
girl she was like she was like shaking
right she was like oh my God like Nick
from JK and I was like what the [__] oh
this is weird and then tip is like
she's like what the [__] is going on
this is hella weird you know she was so
nice we were talking to her for a little
bit she was like oh me and my mom watch
JK every day and I was like oh my God
people really watch the show it's before
like I know people watch the show but
it's like it's weird when someone comes
up to you first time and then like tells
you that and they're complete strangers
it's just like it's a you're gonna blend
the world exactly like you're like oh
[__] this thing that I do every couple
weeks is being seen by people in the big
eye like it's just weird that's pretty
[__] sick man it's like a weird uh um
mindset shift I guess but everyone's
been really [__] nice I haven't
really had anybody I would say like 99.9
of our fans throughout the years have
been [__] amazing yeah for sure you
know what's crazy we were at uh
Albertsons
and then uh I think a couple came up to
us as me Gio and taika and then you
could tell that they're being kind of
like they're just maybe a little bit
like nervous or whatever
um but they're fans and um they're kind
of stuttering or whatever and taika can
feel it so Tiger goes do you wanna and
I'm like and then afterwards and then
afterwards I was like don't say stuff
like that he goes well I'm just gonna
ask him if they want a picture I'm like
I'm like you don't ask them because why
but we're famous oh no no that's not how
it works I mean that's not how it goes
if they want a picture they'll ask for a
picture but then it was just crazy and
I'm like damn this but we're famous in
this world that's just his world is just
different you know and I'm like that's
nuts because he's he's been there since
day one where he's been famous since a
baby it's a baby we always get pictures
so to him it's just such a normal thing
and so if he sees oh dude this is that
awkward behavior that they don't know
how to express like that so you can
snuff it out oh you want a picture yeah
yeah you want a picture that's wild he's
all trying to be nice to them yeah yeah
and he's such a good sport about it you
know like it's hard to get kids to take
pictures right like even us when we're
kids like our dad's about here take a
picture and you're like you have so many
pictures
like tiger could be in the middle of
something if someone wants a picture
he's like that's so cute yeah he's so
good that's cute Hannah said that every
single time there's like a circle of
giggling Asian Chads she knows that
they're gonna ask for pictures
that's tight giggling Asian chat yeah
let's Asian chat what do you mean he's
like your fans she's like 90 of them
have a look like they're like she's like
well also it's being a racist yeah she
can't say that first of all they're
Asian
and they got that little tiniest little
eyes I've ever seen she's like they're
she's like they're fit well-dressed
dudes and that's racist they're wearing
kimonos yeah okay she said they're
they're fit well-dressed dudes and if
they're a giggling Asian Chad then
guaranteed they're gonna ask for a
picture that's pretty cool she says if
she sees a circle of fit well-dressed
dudes that are looking at us then she
goes yeah those guys are fast but she
says that in the UK what she's noticed
is our fan base there is different from
here out there we have a lot of like uh
Brown folks like Muslim uh [__] like
Pakistani
um
like that and then like like the Asians
out there yeah
[Music]
foreign